[Music]
imagine a world where we could travel
again USA at Lowood deeper imagine a
world imagine a world where you can
travel without the fear
I'm inches off the wrong man think basic
privileges that we had before like no
now you could step outside of your house
for one second
what would you guys want to go where the
[ __ ] exists where is that I'm going
where we Joe goes Thailand that was the
one place on my bucket list sitting it's
also even saying we're gonna travel for
a hella long yeah we never did like a
solo travel thing we should do it I just
want to go to Hawaii
relax I have to cancel my trip to Hawaii
I don't know people can't keep up with
my pace I think that's what it is
what is your pace pretty chill that's
hard to keep up with you get out of here
yeah so people are faster than your
piece yeah no I don't know oh you like
to explore I just like randomness
sometimes I play with the plan sometimes
I don't you know and you know I don't
know I don't I
do you know what I realized is I thought
I like traveling with people and then
for the longest time a brother was like
why do you like having to negotiate
every single time like I do whatever the
[ __ ] I want right and then I was like oh
that makes sense because you can't be
selfish when you're on a trip sometime
yeah there with other people that's true
for the most part Steve and I have the
same traveling style where we mostly
want to be on a tropical beach and just
drink and like chill yeah then sometimes
like in Bali I wanted to go to all these
like places worth like the monkey jungle
yeah Forest and like there's this place
where you go to this these like
waterfalls that are up in the mountains
need to hike there and then you go down
this waterfall slide and he was like
bitching about every excursion he's
ain't trying to hike no he does not
wanna that was actually the best time
you ever had
cuz I made him gone it's great cuz it
opens them up right yeah that's why I
like traveling with people I don't like
want things enough when I travel so if I
follow the people's plans I'm like oh
that's cool that's fun yeah I'm down
I'm just down for it people are having a
good time I'm down for whatever yeah
that's all I'm like as long as we're
gonna eat when I want to eat yeah yeah
that's good food yeah my people don't
like food dude balling is the best food
I don't the fruit thick 2bc gonna be oh
my god it's the end every morning like
most of the resorts which are by the way
less than $100 a night all the resorts
have like free buffet breakfast is huge
so the most expensive thing is the
ticket once you got there even that is
like a coach ticket was like 600 bucks
roundtrip yeah but like I wouldn't
recommend flying coach especially if you
have longer legs because it's a 23 hour
flight well I'm compact one is commute
hours is it worth going yeah hello worth
going to how long you stay also if you
upgrade a business class it's not that
much more was $1,800 more twice what's
the three times the ticket you're in
you're in first class you can plus the
600 AD but most business class places
they're like $5,000 but this is like
1,800 and then you don't have to pay for
much when you're there do you stop or is
it just one you have to stop
oh that's why that's why it's 23 hours
you know what's scary though there's all
these airlines going on a business right
or like going into hella debt so what if
by the time we can travel half the
routes are gone and it's more expensive
yeah well there's still gonna be base
across to get to some places you might
have to do more stuff nothing exotic
places like the fun place you have to
get there - somehow I don't want to take
five stops - to Hawaii know what
Sacramento back down to the last but you
keep speaking of people because they
they do their routes they go the routes
not like with our whole carpet yeah they
don't they don't do routes based off the
most logical they go what's the most
profitable it's spirit sometimes it goes
like this for some reason
sure any ask you guys a question then
how many routes are you guys willing to
take to get to Wuhan China
I never wanted why would I want to go
there Wow that survey said they this is
data comes with increase of tourism 20
million social media accounts and
different like one-on-one interviews
15,000 questionnaires all combined
together - and they got
a consensus that most Chinese travelers
are wanting to visit Wuhan and Tony try
they troll it no oh you want to
curiosity
I think it's carryout because they want
to see you work or in a comp from the
concentration camps or Chernobyl yes
it's like Chernobyl yeah exactly
but like way sooner I mean can you
imagine they go to the market and
everyone's buying stuffed animal bats
and [ __ ] like that's not oh you cuz you
said in 2020 and 2020 that's their
sensibility when it comes to the humor
and stuff though I feel like it's like
the next day it's cool it's maybe
picking up the virus is like picking up
a souvenir you know but honestly I would
rather go there then most places in
America right now because of how clean
they are and how not clean they were but
I mean they are they had a there they
had their lockdown right there coin and
then they when they opened it back up
and now they're trying to get some cases
again like everywhere in the world but
their cases aren't as crazy as the rest
back as a report that's true but oh no
then they're sorry that once again I
think we've got like a few new confirmed
cases so they're testing every single
person yeah they are you cannot you
can't go into a restaurant without first
showing your ID number getting your
temperature check yeah and then you
always have to keep your health status
up to date on this app so when you show
them that we're agree and you can go in
okay that's cool I'll go to China I want
some real Chinese hot pot it's there's a
lot of things over there that they can
only do in China cuz no one you can't
track people the same way you can track
true it's not communist here you don't
want to be like oh this is my bar code
silly its communist you without being
communist what here or in China here
here yeah California maybe I actually
feel like it I mean it's not being
communist anywhere you go at this point
they just say it's great it's just other
places are less communist you say no you
see communist you mean just like corrupt
government that controls everybody cuz
they're controlling this oh no we don't
know we're not saying that no no because
Huntington Beach a Newport Beach they
sued the state of California so I think
they're trying like [ __ ] off our backs
this my city yeah dude I heard that
people were getting arrested on the
beach even being like social distance
away they were getting arrested
and then take it to jail where they're
like in calm fines with other people see
that's why I like I like having white
neighbors and living in the white
neighborhood cuz they'll Karen the [ __ ]
out of the gun yeah they'll be like let
me talk to the manager and the president
love the Karen yeah and don't [ __ ]
like do something and I'm like thank you
because if we try we just yeah I don't
have to do [ __ ] but you were doing it
and I felt it well you know I got a
restaurant and they like this the kids
in the back that are making the food are
like just talking to each other and like
you're waiting how long yep yeah you're
not gonna say anything but the white
lady you're like yeah I know like do it
she's gonna say something some of them
are helpful to it how long you wait here
people yeah it's the meltdown Karen's
that are scary yeah there's good pens
back carrots the hall monitor Karen's
are the ones you're like the carrots you
hear about they're being reversed
Karen's now like it's not white people
getting called the police on because
they're gathering in groups florentine
so now they're getting caught on the
river yeah
but they're the ones that complain
they're like this is my ride this mine
yeah but then there's no one bigger than
the police call it on so it's Karen on
Karen crime yeah so Karen's calling sher
and there's a battle that is a Karen
battle dude there's a neighborhood watch
battle versus like I got my rights
battle when I drive through the
neighborhood I do see people's like
chairs that are set up in their front
lawn and you can tell it's been like
that for weeks like faded pillows or you
could see like the it's brown where the
the chair is touching the lawn so I
think that's just part of their usual
thing I like I'm gonna come out to my
front none I get to talk to my neighbor
yeah cuz like yeah it's like that
quarantine life is so like embedded now
I've seen people have a quarantine
picnics so they'll meet up with their
friends in six feet away yeah their
blankets a little bit far apart but you
still talk and hang out I've seen
quarantined Tai Chi there's like 20
Asian ladies and they're all like six to
eight feet apart and they're all doing
it cause they're apart big enough for
that probably always done it no no
yeah like if they're not that far apart
wouldn't they hit each other no this one
it's like really far though you can tell
they made the effort or the masks
together and wearing masks that never
changed yeah that's cute but yeah if you
were interested in traveling the china
book that Wuhan overtook Beijing at the
top domestic city for Chinese travelers
on the wish list and before Wuhan only
ranked number eight is there stuff to do
there I don't know yeah I don't know I
didn't know anything about Wuhan until I
mean it's like the area 51 a China now
yeah that's like they got a even before
there's so many foreigners I got stuck
there because they quarantined they got
a lockdown so the hello like Americans
how to get rescued how lost really it's
all like why the [ __ ] were there in the
first place well teachers I know a lot
of them yeah they teaching business
that's the main thing I I have to come
to know some of these places are super
international like oh yeah you know I
was in Beijing you know I was at a club
there and I saw like the whole African
Mafia like it was crazy extra I was in
Macau and then like like and there's
like this really popular area Macau
where there's like clubs and stuff and
like it was only African like club
people trying to get you to go in and it
says it almost looked like like you're
just like in Africa all of a sudden you
know the number one interracial couple
in Africa is Chinese Chinese and black
Chinese and black because of the trade
that happens between all right cuz
China's going into Africa a lot in like
building [ __ ] and doing all that yeah
Wow a lot of blasian babies a lot of
black anis
I'm not way more white Africans then
black Africans South Africa
yeah South Africans like there's so many
South Africans were like I'm African I'm
like a white guy from South Africa if he
comes and becomes American is the
african-american now yeah technically
yeah but no not really
so think it's funny when Americans go to
like Europe and they still call black
people african-american they're like
Burma America no trying to be
politically correct is this how that
works that's how the rest of the world
looks at us like why the [ __ ] are you
like Asian American or like like what
like because they they just if they're
Dutch they're just
you're like a comedian but you don't go
even British I've never heard of that or
whatever chinese-american rival that's
like try just say I'm American I belong
I'm mixed so I guess maybe that's if you
have to specify like I just I feel like
America is a melting pot like we're just
American if you're born here you're
American American doesn't mean white
anymore yeah almost sounds healthier to
acknowledge its just American American
consumer right when you go to like you
love there some what are some where any
of those countries they're like nah
you're American yeah you tried to I have
to somebody who's like hey what are you
American but what I because Americans
don't want to be Americans do that
that's true all the Americans do that to
the minorities here yeah cuz when I was
traveling they're like oh he's an
American exact they don't go but what
kind of American where are you from from
yeah they don't say the only America -
that's not very global even though we're
a melting pot yeah we're not people are
so afraid of being classified as
American that they think if you ask why
people here like like one you don't you
already can see what they are but Irish
some are like who like from when and
they're like five six maybe ten
generations back like you know me I'm
Irish I'm a good old green Irish and
it's like for how long I don't remember
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]